STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
It's Stephanie Wong, back again.
I'm a cloud developer
advocate, and I
am thrilled because we have Eric
Brewer, our Google fellow, here
with me again today.
We are doing a series of videos.
And we are talking
about Google Kubernetes
Engine for next-gen developers.
Eric, welcome back.
ERIC BREWER: Great to be here.
Thank you.
STEPHANIE WONG: I want to
talk about some of the most
common questions that both you
and I, and I think a lot of us
here at Google Cloud, have
gotten, the first being, what
is the difference
between Kubernetes-- that
is, Google Kubernetes Engine
in particular-- and serverless?
ERIC BREWER: Well,
they're both the future.
So in that sense, they're
easy to get confused.
But I would say
the main difference
is Kubernetes, and
GKE in particular,
are a really great
platform for building
a wide range of services.
And that's really the key.
You can build all
kinds of services
on top of Kubernetes and GKE.
Serverless, especially
classically defined,
obviously, means no servers.
But it usually means
functions as a service
or request-reply patterns
in particular websites.
And so that is an
example, one of many,
of a domain-specific solution.
And in general, when you have
a domain-specific solution
like Cloud Run, you
could do a fantastic job
for that domain that is much
easier to use than Kubernetes.
So if you know exactly what you
want to do and it's opinionated
and it's narrow, you should
build that as a Platform
as a Service.
If you're going to build
all kinds of things,
like your enterprise, Kubernetes
is the great base for that.
And in fact, I see lots
of enterprises building
internal Platforms as a
Service of various kinds on top
of Kubernetes.
And that combination makes
a huge amount of sense.
STEPHANIE WONG: So it sounds
like if you have a specific use
case that serverless products
are well-equipped for, then,
absolutely, go with that.
But what about in
the case where you
might start with a serverless
product, like Cloud Run, Cloud
Functions, et cetera, and then
you decide later on that we are
fully bought into
Kubernetes and we would
like to broaden our use cases?
We want to build
platforms on top.
Is it possible to have
both in your environment?
ERIC BREWER: Lots
of customers use
both today in very
interesting combinations.
There are certainly
customers that
started out on App
Engine or Cloud Run
and have moved to
Kubernetes because they
want finer grained control
over all the details.
That's one reason.
And in fact, they're rebuilding
a customized platform
internally for themselves.
There are other groups
that use something
like Cloud Run for
the front-end services
and use Kubernetes
for back-end services.
That also makes a lot
of sense because you
can do a lot of data management
control in Kubernetes.
There are groups-- I
know of at least one
that uses both for
different reasons, which
is they have a
Kubernetes cluster that
does their main load.
But when they have a hot
spot, like a Black Friday,
they actually use Cloud
Run to absorb the spikes.
And so there's lots of ways
to make this work, really,
depending on what
cleverness you want
to play to mix these together.
But they're definitely--
they work well together.
And you can start on Cloud
Run and move to Kubernetes
later-- is another
really common pattern.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
here's a thought.
So we've talked about
this a little bit
in our previous videos--
about how platform teams want
to use Kubernetes,
and yet they also
want to customize their
platforms for their needs.
We talked about policy
enforcement as an example.
So how should an enterprise
use Kubernetes Engine?
ERIC BREWER: Well, in
general, a cloud provider
offers more things
than you, really, would
like your developers to use.
And what I mean by that is
if you're an enterprise,
you have a platform
team, and you say, oh,
we're building this kind
of financial service,
we really don't want to
give our internal developers
all possibilities.
We don't really want them to be
in charge of their own credit
card transactions, for example.
That's a highly regulated thing.
It needs to be done very
carefully with careful audit
logs.
And so really,
what I'd like to do
is give my internal
developers a platform
where they can do credit
card transactions that
are guaranteed by the
structure of the services
to be compliant with all
regulations-- and by the way,
in all different countries
in which we operate.
And so I see
Kubernetes as the way
to build these customized
platforms, where they enforce
whatever rules the enterprise
cares about through things
like control over
project creation,
control over the nodes you use,
control over the OS you use,
control over the libraries
and repos you pull from.
Those kinds of
background controls
are things that
are not typically
up to the internal developers to
decide, but, at the same time,
provides services framework,
possibly something like Anthos
Service Mesh to manage
services across these things
and give their
developers, again,
the productivity that you want
and the velocity of features,
but, again, in a
way that's decoupled
from risk around certain
features that are highly
regulated, especially.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, and it sounds
like there is very
much a culture
and organizational structure
in place in which you
have your operators
and administrators
and your developers.
Now, we do have a
lot of curiosity
out there in the
community about advice
for these next generation
of Kubernetes developers.
And we've actually
collected some of them.
I know that you threw
out a prompt for AMA
questions on your Twitter,
and so did I. So get excited,
everyone.
We are going to come back in
the next video with a handful
of those questions.
So stay tuned.
And thank you so much, Eric.
ERIC BREWER: Looking
forward to it.
Thank you.